so we've seen in the last few videos if
we start with a logistic differential
equation where we have R which is our R
proportional or essentially as a
constant that says how fast are we
growing when we're unconstrained by
environmental limits and then we have K
which we can view as the maximum
population given our constraints we saw
that if we wanted to solve this and we
didn't want one of the constant
solutions of n of T equals zero or n of
T is equal to K and we did this in the
last few videos we got the solution that
n of T n of T is equal to is equal to
our initial n n naught times our maximum
population all of that over all of that
over our initial population our initial
population plus the difference between
our maximum population and the initial
population so K - and not K minus n
naught times e e to the negative RT e to
the negative R R T but this right over
here this logistic function this
logistic function is a non constant
solution and it's the interesting one we
care about if we're going to model a
population - the logistic - the logistic
differential equation so now that we've
done all that work to come up with this
let's actually apply that was a whole
goal is to model population growth and
so let's say let's come up with some
assumptions let's first think about well
let's say that I have an island so let's
say this is my island and I start it and
I start settling it with a hundred a
hundred people so I'm essentially saying
and not let me do that in the end not
color so I'm saying n naught is equal to
100 and let's say this environment given
given what
current technology of farming and
agriculture and the availability of
water and whatever else let's say it can
only support let's say it can only I
want to that green let's say it can only
support 1,000 people max so you get the
idea
so we get K capital K is equal to 1000
that's the limit to the population and
so now we have to think about what is
our going to be so we have to come up
with some assumptions so let's say in a
generation and a generation which is
about twenty years well I'll just assume
in twenty years I think it's reasonable
that the population grows by let's say
the population grows by 50 percent in 20
years you have 50 percent growth 50
percent increase increase in the actual
population so what would that what would
you have to have your annual increase in
order to for after 20 years to grow by
50% well to think about that I'll get
out my calculator and one way to think
about it growing by 50 percent that
means that you are at 1.5 your original
population and if I take that to the
120th power so the 120th of all I
understood 1 divided by xx this
essentially says well how much are am I
going to grow by or what is going to
this this is telling me that I'm going
to grow by a factor of 1.0 to every year
1.0 204 8 and so one way to think about
it is every year if I grow by if every
year if every year I grow by if every
year I grow by what 0.020 I'll just
round 5 then over 20 years as this
compounds I will have grown by 50 I will
have grown by 50% so that would be our
our this is essentially how much we are
going to grow each year let me write
that growth
growth each year and we're going to
assume that our tea here is in years so
we're going to assume that our T is in
years so T is in years so what would our
logistic function look like given all of
these assumptions we would have n of T
let me n of T is equal to is equal to n
naught times K that's going to be a
hundred times a thousand it's going to
be one hundred 100 times 1,000 my
initial population times my maximum
population divided by divided by my
initial population my initial population
plus the difference between my final and
initial so it's 1,000 minus 100 so
that's going to be this right over here
is going to be 900 900 times e to the
negative R so the negative 0.02 0-5
times T times T so it will be equal to
that and to verify that this actually is
this actually does describe population
in a way that we thought the logistic
differential equation would let's
actually plot it so let me if you pause
this video and then plot it so there you
go I made a plot and I copied and pasted
it here and we see the behavior that we
wanted the behavior that we wanted to
see we see the population right over
here it's at Year Zero is starting at
100 let me do this in a color that
you're more likely to see population
starts at 100 and we can see that let's
see after 20 years our population looks
like it's almost grown to 150 so it
looks like at least in the beginning
this this term this right over here is
dominating we are growing by this this
point 0 205 that would be 2 point
zero 5% per year which gets us close to
50% growth and we see that's what's
happening initially so we go from 100
150 in the first 20 years in the first
generation and then in the next
generation we should add another 75 if
we weren't kind of being constrained by
the environment 150 plus 75 would be 225
and it looks like we got after 20 years
to about 200 so we're a little bit
slower we're a little bit slower than
kind of the pure exponential growth but
we're you know the pure exponential
growth would probably have us tracking
something closer to here but still
growing pretty well but then as our
population gets larger and larger larger
is waiting closer and closer to the
maximum population our rate of growth
our rate of growth is approaching is
approaching zero so we constantly
approach our maximum population but we
never but we never quite get there it's
really an asymptote we're just
approaching it as time goes on and on
and on but you can kind of set your own
threshold if you want to say okay when
do we get to kind of 90 percent of
maximum population well that looks like
that happens 90 percent of maximum
population happened after 210 years on
this island so on a human scale that
seems like a long time many generations
but in I guess in a cosmic scale it's so
it's not that long not even a cosmic
scale you know just slightly longer than
a than a human scale and so it'll it'll
happen well this just describes what's
happening and so this isn't there's a
pretty interesting model and would be
I'd be interested to see how it actually
compares with actual data out there for
actual population growth with that said
we it's not this this you know
everything that we've done so far has
always assumed we're kind of assuming
this idea of a Malthusian limit but what
we've learned from human history is that
this Malthusian limit seems to get keeps
getting pushed higher and higher based
on the improvement of technology that
we're able to grow more crops in a
certain amount of area we have better
rule of law so people don't kill each
other is often we have better control of
water and irrigation and all of these
things so that we're able to
increase the limits then far beyond what
we thought I would guess if you told if
we told Thomas Malthus that in the year
2014 we have 7 billion people on the
earth he would have said that's far
beyond the Malthusian limit he probably
would have guessed that the Malthusian
limit was more like a billion or two
billion given the technology the time
and we're already at 7 billion in his
technology improves in agriculture
improves the rule of law improves and
everything improves we might be able to
get who knows there might be a time we
might think it's crazy for there to be
20 billion people on the planet but
given today's technology but if
technology improves and optimistic
scenarios that maybe maybe we could keep
going not necessarily that's that's not
necessarily a good thing but we it just
might be what it is